hi yes
does that better
yeah okay
um very cool so thank you so much for
coming and I want to thank the
organizers so much for the invitation to
come here I came all the way from Brazil
it's been a long trip but so worth it
um the just the presentations the
excellent content and the people that I
got to meet here I'm just really
enjoying this is my first Pi data event
and I'm really really happy to be here
so thank you so much
um so yeah thank you I'm here to talk
about uh some of the work that we've
been doing at kwanzai but also in
collaboration with a bunch of people in
different open source communities my
talk is called can we optimize
communities and I swear it's gonna make
sense
so I don't usually do bio slides
especially if someone else is
introducing me but I feel like this time
I should mention it
um I do feel kind of like a newcomer to
open source even though I have been
around the communities for a long time
when I joined the university as an
undergrad in 1999 I landed at a math
department that was like Linux only and
you need to get with the cool kids and
only use free software so that was my
first encounter with that kind of stuff
and
even though I kept working on math and
applied math and going to my whole
academic career I was never too far away
from open source and free software I
really enjoyed the community so I
participated in like meetups and
organization of events education
Outreach teaching my students how to
code teaching my students how to do
latex teaching my students how to do
installing Ubuntu and whatever so I feel
kind of like a newcomer but I joined
coincide around three years ago and
after 10 years as a professor at the
University in Brazil so I was working in
the math department doing
um Applied Mathematics specific
specifically optimization numerical
optimization
and the reason I left is basically
because I realized that I was not that
good at research and so I was going to
maybe write papers that would get read
by like three people or perhaps like the
reviewers if that and then I realized
working on open source you have so much
impact in the lives of people there's so
much that you can do and I had this
great opportunity to join quansite after
participating on a Sprint for nampai and
sci-fi at the Sci-Fi conference in
Austin Texas in 2019 so if you folks
participated in a Sprint at Pi data keep
your eye out like this is cool you can
have cool opportunities doing that kind
of work
um so like I said I was working
um in applied math doing research
software development also in Fortran
Matlab and then python
and I signed up for like numpy
discussion and sci-fi user I don't know
how many years ago and I kept seeing the
names of people come up you know and
today I get to work with these people
it's just really exciting but I had
never had the courage to actually be a
contributor it took me a long time to
like really decide to do this and send a
PRN and participate in discussions
because I felt like I was not good
enough right
um so I look I kind of call myself a
junior senior because I feel like I have
a lot of experience in some things like
teaching and doing that kind of stuff
but I don't have that much experience in
like the actual um corporate side or
industry side so I'm I feel like I'm
still understanding how this works
so my field of research when I was
working at the University was numerical
optimization like I said and
optimization is defined as the action of
making the best or most effective use of
a situation or resource right so because
I wanted to give a shout out to Matlab I
made a nice plot
and this is a plot that everyone knows I
think it's very very
um ubiquitous like there's book covers
with this plot and you know examples in
the documentation but basically the idea
is that you have this function which is
a complicated non-linear function right
with Hills and Valleys and different
ways that it behaves in different
regions
and that's kind of how it works in
non-linear optimization which is trying
to find the best point in this case it
could be a maximum or it could be a
minimum of the function in like a big
region
functions like this don't necessarily
have a single Optimum point right you
could have several so you could have
local Optima you could have Global
Optima and for a global optimization
problem with a non-linear function there
are just no good Solutions there's no
solver that does that because you would
have to search the entire space for the
best solution and so it is really hard
to solve that problem
in fact there's this person a very
famous Professor in convex optimization
called Yuri nestorov and he once said
that optimization is the art of solving
impossible problems that's kind of how I
feel here so life you know as it turns
out is highly non-linear and it's not a
well-behaved function so that's what I'm
trying to draw the parallel here
and because I wanted to go a little
further I did some animation and you can
do that with math lav
so you can see the contour lines and
everything
cool so
um currently I am involved in a two-year
joint Grant awarded by the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative and supported by
quantite and numb Focus for numpy sci-fi
math plot lib and pandas like for very
tiny projects that nobody knows about
and very very
um like not mainstream at all
this is a diversity and inclusion
supplement Grant attached to their
essential open source software for
science program where they are funding
these fundamental projects and software
communities that allow people to do
biomedical research to do all other
kinds of like scientific advancements
um and it's a really nice program
so our grant involves supporting the
onboarding inclusion and retention of
people from historically marginalized
groups on Scientific Python and to
improve the community dynamics of these
four open source projects
we are halfway there so it's been a year
since we started this work and we still
have a year to go
so what I want to talk about today is
kind of how is this going is this
working or not what have we tried and
what kind of things do we want to do in
the future
so
to do this work uh when we started
coming up with this grant we had to come
up with a proposal and explain what we
wanted to do we kind of came up this
idea of a contributor experience lead so
you can think of this as kind of a
developer experience like a kind of
helping people get around and understand
uh how to make it easier for folks to
contribute and how to make it easier for
them to understand not only the
technical side but also how to interact
with the communities
um and so what what can you we say is
contributor experience so I have a few
items here I can see these three axes of
work
first there is the side of communication
uh which involves documentation hosting
organizing uh Community meetings
um
organizing feedback receiving processing
and passing along feedback that we
receive not necessarily from users but
more from other contributors and
maintainers
and doing some Outreach right so the
talk that I'm giving here right now
um uh meetups uh Community meetings from
other projects that's also something
that we're interested in
a second axis of this work is governance
um so remember
when we started this work and I'm gonna
be uh get into more detail about that
later we were not necessarily part of
these communities so we are not in
governance positions right but the idea
is that as newcomers we can take a look
and see what is explicit and what is
implicit in the organization of these
communities so we can identify and
document roles and responsibilities
inside the projects
um
facilitate open conversations around
road map building around maintenance
load around what can we do to make it
easier for people to work on these
projects
leadership support in case we need to
communicate with the community with the
other contributors with the other
maintainers all that kind of stuff and I
put in code of conduct but I put in like
a little bit different because we are
not necessarily focusing on enforcing
codes of conduct or writing codes of
conduct that's not the focus of our work
that's another full-time job and that's
not something that we do but we do like
we can't avoid also paying attention to
how that is done and if there's anything
that we can do to help improve the
situation for the projects we're working
on
and then there is the meat of this work
which is the contributor's support so we
want to make sure that we are helping
onboard new contributors that they
understand how to ask for help and where
they can go to get that help uh we are
hosting organizing new contributor
meetings so that people can understand
how to get started can ask questions
meet the maintainers on all of that uh
we can help establish teams for example
when that is necessary so maybe a triage
team or a documentation Team all of that
depends on the project that we're
working on
scaffolding contributions and this is
something that we were discussing today
earlier at the fireside chat so creating
opportunities for people to pick
contribution tasks that are
appropriate to their time commitment to
their experience level and to their
interests and so maybe coming up with
tiny contributions to documentation or
other parts of community building that
people can take on and do in an hour or
two instead of spending 20 hours solving
a complicated bug that you know maybe
they'll give up in the middle just
because they don't have the time
and finally mentoring encouragement
empowerment anything that we can do to
make people feel safer to make people
feel welcome to make people feel like
they can actually step up and do this as
well
so I told you that these positions that
we were thinking of were called
contributor experience lead so why do we
include this lead in the title uh of
this position because we do feel like
this is some kind of leadership position
in the sense that we do need to decide
what's going to be done and we do need
to work with the maintainers to
understand what they need and this
involves kind of it's more or less a
senior position in the sense that you
need to understand how communities work
you need to have some experience with
people to be able to make that work
so a few of the skills that we have uh
identified as being part of these
activities that we are developing are
for example on the technical side we can
do documentation tooling uh so one that
we are experimenting with for example is
get pod has anyone ever heard of gitpod
very few people Tom
um so gitpod is a really nice tool that
you can use for people to set up like
actually they don't have to set up a
developer environment on their own
machines they can do that on the browser
so they can go to your repo click a
button and they have on the browser a
full developer setup and they can just
get started with contributions don't
need to worry about condo packaging
about Windows builds about compiler
support nothing it's really wonderful
and that was my like like you can pay me
get fun
um
and we can also do small feature
development right we need to feel the
pain of the contributors we need to
understand where they might have trouble
we need to understand where the process
is not clear where the workflow can be
improved and so that is also part of the
work that we do
um another part of it is communication
so like I said Outreach talks uh
knowledge brokering understanding who
knows about this and who can we ask to
understand how this work and connecting
people so that they can have that point
of contact in case they need that
information in the future this might
seem very like small or very
non-important like people can go and
look to the documentation right just
read the manual but that's usually not
how it works there's a lot of implicit
knowledge inside these projects of how
for example I'll give you a very
concrete example that happened to me I
spent a long time trying to understand
when someone does a commit message that
is not in agreement with what we require
in documentation how should I fix it do
I push to their Branch or do I squash
the whole thing and then change the
commit message those are things that are
really not that documented maintainers
do that and they don't really think
about it but if someone else is coming
in and trying to step up and be a
maintainer they need to have that
information right
um another aspect of this is program
management so we have meeting
facilitation event planning we can try
and help with Road mapping there's a
number of different things that we can
do in this area
with governance we're focusing on
reporting ensuring trying to facilitate
growth and sustainability for projects
uh Internal Documentation like I
mentioned before but also helping with
funding potentially
um proposals and that kind of thing
and in the end what I think is the more
important part is the interpersonal
skills you need to be able to make
connections with people and you're going
to see me talking about this a lot
because I really do think that this is
the heart of the work
which is having this community
engagement collaboration training being
able to build that network of
collaborators inside a project
foreign
the contributor experience team is
actually made of three people right now
so it is me Noah kamir and in asaposan
Noah is also working at quantite and
Vanessa is working at Albus code and
together we are split across these four
projects so inessa is focused on numpy
I am splitting my time between sci-fi
and matplotlib and Noah is splitting her
time between matplotlib and fundus
so what have we done so far like I said
we are a year into the grant so we have
tried a few things we have experimented
with a few things
um I can point to a few things that we
did that I think were successful uh for
example the first thing that you notice
is the new contributor meetings how many
people have heard of these new
contributor meetings
oh you need to know about this folks so
if you are on Twitter you can follow all
the four projects they have Twitter
accounts or you can be old people like
me and follow the mailing list and then
you can get the information about the
new contributor meetings for all the
four projects so what are what are these
meetings so mostly we want people to
have an opportunity to connect with
other maintainers and to come and say
hey I would really like to contribute to
pandas but I don't know where to start
should I look for the good first issue
should I go for a documentation issue
first how do I ask people how to get
started I tried but I couldn't get my
developers set up working
all of those questions are things that
you can compensate at a new contributor
meeting
um so all the four projects now have new
contributor meetings so you're welcome
to join any of those depending on your
time zone a few projects are alternating
time zones to be a little bit more
inclusive
um other things that are here so for
example we have
um specifically for numpy inessa has
been organizing the new contributor
meetings in two formats so sometimes we
have those open Office hours where
people come and ask questions other
times we have webinar like events where
the maintainers we will explain how they
do things so we had one very fun Edition
where it was like four different
maintainers explaining how they find
functions in the numpy code base
basically everyone uses grep just so you
know but that's the idea we don't know
where the functions are nobody knows
that by heart but you would never think
that by watching how maintainers work
you can actually understand well I could
actually do that too I can also do grab
right so it makes it a little bit easier
to understand how the work is done
um we also have a few policy things so
for example you can see Anessa added a
policy about enactive PRS and numpy have
you seen how many PRS we have open in
Mumbai
it's a disaster but it is because many
times people leave and they give up and
they don't want to come back and finish
their PRS and maybe someone else wants
to take over and finish that PR but we
never know should we close it should we
ask people to come back so we're trying
to organize this so that people know
from the start they will know if six
months are passed and I don't give any
response on this PR someone else is free
to take over and finish it for me
um uh there's also an open PR about a
triage guide for sci-fi a few fixes and
improvements to documentation uh Noah is
working on get bot actions for pandas
there's a bunch of different things that
we're doing as part of this work and
there's also a lot of things that did
not show up here right that are just in
the background conversations talking to
people encouraging them to contribute to
coming to participate in the communities
oh and one last thing that I forgot to
say is um
we have also established secondary
communication channels for the four
projects some of them had this already
so uh matplotlib had a gator channel
that was already working and numpy had a
slack channel so we did the same for
sci-fi and Panda so sci-fi and pandas
now also have slack spaces you can feel
free sorry feel free to join and those
are meant to be like more informal
discussions and conversations that maybe
you don't want to have on GitHub right I
don't want to ask my question on GitHub
where it will live forever so maybe I
want to go to slightly more private
space where I can go and ask how do I do
this I don't really know how to go for
it here so this has been working we can
see some movement of people coming and
asking questions on these communication
channels
but we also understood when we started
working and you can see this from uh the
examples that I'm giving here is that
not every project needs exactly the same
thing right uh projects are different
they have their own organization and we
need to respect that it's not like
coming in and doing everything different
we need to understand what they need and
we need to understand how to provide
that for them the best way that we can
and so a few projects needed more policy
other others needed more tooling it
really depends on how the project has
been developing historically
so then after I explain all this first
question that comes to people's minds I
think a lot of people will come and say
well does it work
what you're doing is that working
um so
I put in a definition here because I'm a
mathematician and I like definition so a
function when it is to be optimized you
call it an objective function a utility
function or a fitness function sometimes
as an energy function and what you want
to do is either minimize or maximize
that function to reach an optimal
solution
so that's what we're asking right is it
working
are we going towards an optimal solution
are we minimizing the energy are we
maximizing the output what are we doing
here and what how can we measure that
this is working
so an optimization uh when we have a
complicated function and we don't
necessarily know what it what shape it
has and what are the derivatives and how
it really behaves
we call a specific routine that can just
spit out the value for us and we can
evaluate what's happening that's called
an oracle uh like just like the Greek
oracle that will tell you the future
right so we want to query that function
and it will give you your Oracle
like I said life is a complicated
function
we don't know how it looks like we don't
know what these trajectories look like
so all that we have are oracles we have
proxies to tell us if this is working or
not these are our metrics right
so mostly people focus on GitHub and
some
flow of communication in these
communication channels that I mentioned
like slack or stack Overflow or whatever
other tool that you're using
so we can monitor contribution stats you
can monitor traffic of conversations
that kind of stuff
other people will say well we can also
measure popularity or social media
engagement like followers downloads how
many people are retweeting and when I
say downloads is also like package
downloads like Pi Pi conda that kind of
stuff
and then you can also measure uh events
and Outreach for example how many people
are coming to my Sprint
how many of those actually did PRS how
many people are coming to my newcomer
meetings all of those are metrics that
we can use
would we as contributor experience leads
be counted in our own metrics
not necessarily like I said there's a
lot of work that we do in the background
that does not get counted by any of
these metrics they don't capture the
whole thing they will capture a piece of
the information and the final output of
the work but they will not necessarily
capture all the hours that we spend
organizing planning and thinking and
coming up with new strategies or dming
people to ask hey I haven't seen you
around the repo for a while is
everything okay do you need help with
anything none of that comes out in these
metrics
so I have a really nice picture here of
my favorite Community I'm sorry folks
this is python Brazil and it happened
around a month ago in manaus we didn't
have the full community there we're
still dealing with covid and learning
how to do things a lot of people were
online but the people who were there we
took this nice picture and what I think
about when I see this picture is that
I wanted to go to python Brazil which is
our local pycon not because I wanted to
see the talks not because I wanted to
really learn things about python but
because I miss my friends it had been
three years since I had seen them and I
bet some of you here are also having the
same experience coming back to Phi data
um so we want to meet people we want to
talk we want to connect and communities
are made of people ultimately that's
what we want to do when we join a
community
but then who are we so I want to show I
I'm complaining about metrics and then
I'm going to show some metrics but bear
with me so
um the Linux Foundation had a survey
last year about diversity equity and
inclusion and it's basically the only
data reliable data that we have around
open source it's not perfect but it's
what we have right so
for example they got that 82 percent of
the people that participate in open
source and responded to the survey are
men
um 72 percent are from Europe or North
America
[Music]
89 feel they can have a positive impact
on the world I felt like this was really
good this is really nice
and then 82 fuel welcome in open source
that sounds really wonderful right
but then there's a gacha
so when we say feel welcome in open
source
when you look at the 18 who said they do
not feel welcome they are
disproportionately from underrepresented
groups
so something is happening that's not
being captured in the metrics right
when we ask the question when we see the
number we are not seeing the full
picture we are seeing some kind of proxy
for that information but it's not
exactly clear what's happening
they also have a lot of other data and I
really encourage you to look at that
report if you want to take a look at how
our open source communities are
organized and the kind of people who
participate in them uh but I the one
that I wanted to highlight here is that
time is the number one determinant for
participation and every single question
that was about why don't you participate
more or what makes you unable to
contribute to open source the answer was
time and it's not time because people
don't want to spend their time in open
source but maybe they have two jobs
maybe they have to commute for a long
time every day maybe they are Caregivers
for a child or for an elderly family
member and they just don't have the free
time to dedicate to open source
historically we also know that those
people are usually already from
underrepresented groups right
and so this is skewing the whole
observation that we have from the open
source contributors
how can we solve that I don't know I
don't have the answers the only thing
that I know is that I want to understand
what the contributors want so what do
you want when you join a community when
you do volunteer work right you're not
looking for necessarily some money for
your contributions so what do you want
usually people will say they want
professional development they want to
learn how to collaborate in a large open
source project because it is interesting
and they can learn a lot of different
skills like technical communication how
to organize their proposal for fixing
things and that kind of stuff
maybe it's personal fulfillment they
want to feel like they did a
contribution to numpy that is totally
legitimate right
um maybe they want to learn they want to
learn how to do programming better and
they like code reviews code reviews are
a great way to get feedback on how you
program how you do your organize your
code and you can learn from that
maybe they just want to get the green
squares on GitHub that is perfectly fine
I hear a lot from people who say well
people will only come to my open source
project and they just want to get a
green square and then put a line on
their CV that they contributed to this
project and then they're going to leave
that is fine
people have different reasons and
different motivations to contribute to
open source and if we can provide that
if we can help them get there
fine we can do that of course there is
the other side every interaction every
time that you send a message every time
that you send a PR you are asking for a
maintainer attention right so it is a
trade-off it can be exploitative in
either side so there there are things
that we can do to mitigate that but in
the end
each person has their own motivation and
I don't know that we can vet that I
don't know that we can say there are
right reasons and there are right wrong
reasons to contribute to open source
um and finally I think that there's
people who just want to feel connected
they want to feel like they are a part
of a bigger thing an open source
Community a group and we've seen people
for example come to the new contributor
meetings or to the regular Community
they have meetings and they will just
stick around and listen
for like five six meetings on a row and
they're not doing any contributions on
GitHub but they like to listen and they
like to participate in the conversation
that is also great it's cool we're
building Community we're making friends
Okay so
last part is can we improve so are there
things that we can do to improve
um how we organize our communities uh if
any of the things that we are doing we
don't know if they're working or not we
can only have observational data we can
only see the people who are coming to
our projects is there anything that we
can actually do to improve the situation
of diversity of inclusion inclusion in
these open source projects is there
anything we can do to improve
sustainability and make sure that people
come and become maintainers over time
of course most of the people will say
well money right we need to pay the
maintainers
um and I think that's right I think we
do need to pay the maintainers but I
don't think it's only about money
why is it not only about money
um
so usually
when you get money for an open source
project the first instinct and perhaps
that is right if you're having like
limited funds and that's the only money
that you have you want to support the
existing maintainers right they're
already doing the work they're already
involved and they deserve to get
recognition and to get a financial
compensation for their work
however over time what happens is that
only the people who are doing code are
getting paid
and so this will repeat the same cycle
of only the people who are doing code
want to join your project because they
know that this is the only way to get
paid over time this creates the cycle of
no one is doing documentation no one is
doing community building no one is doing
uh design
no one is doing web development and all
of these things end up as side thoughts
something that come later maybe we'll
have the time to do that but not real
Focus uh work that you can do
so this is a lot about what kind of work
do we value on open source projects and
that's the thing that we wanted to
challenge a little bit about our work
how can we make sure that people have
different paths to contribution
so you can see this uh is a print from
the numpy documentation it says I'm not
going to read everything but it says not
a coder not a problem numpy is
multifaceted and you can use we can use
a lot of help there's all of these
things that you can do so there's code
of course there's also Community
coordination devops developing
educational content fundraising
marketing project management
translations website there's a bunch of
different things that you can do
um and this is true this is a big open
source project like this needs all of
these skills and we would like to see
more people coming with these kills to
our open source projects they won't
because it's hard to get credit for
these kinds of contributions if you're
doing design I just learned that GitHub
is previewing this feature where you can
see diffs of images when you do PRS have
you seen this
it's just been announced a few hours ago
I think
um so you can actually see the diffs
between images and so that will help
designers contribute to open source
projects on GitHub usually what you do
is that they have their figma file or
something like that they'll do all the
changes there in the end there's a blob
that goes into the documentation you
don't see all the time that they spent
doing design
so there are tools that try to help this
there's the all contributors tool for
example that allows you to tag a person
and say they are hosting Community
meetings or they are doing design but
it's just one commit right so again it's
not really valued or credited as code is
that is not that that's a it's a GitHub
problem right it's not an us problem we
like that we just don't know how to
credit that within the GitHub system so
maybe we need to look beyond what is the
metrics of GitHub and the green squares
so like I said before
in general optimization problems are
unsolvable
um which means that you can ask yourself
so what is the answer what do we need to
do like I said I don't know we are
trying and when we are trying I like to
think that goes into the sense of
bounded rationality so I came across
this concept and I feel like it's very
interesting
uh this is describes the way that humans
make decisions that are not perfectly
rational in the sense that they are not
the best choices but they are
satisfactory
maybe that's what we need to do we don't
know how to optimize this we don't know
how to find the best solution but we can
do something and we can find
satisfactory solutions that at least get
get us a little bit closer to where we
want to be
so finally I want to mention a little
bit about leadership so of course we are
not doing this work alone there's a
bunch of people in the projects that are
supporting us and helping us and we are
super grateful for that
um and this is a really cool
um print that I got from Matt haverland
from sci-fi so I don't know if you can
see what he's writing there but he says
I accidentally pushed to Maine
and I think I broke everything uh so
this is a revert please check that it
does the right thing uh so breaking
sci-fi right
um and you see in the bottom message
evgeny who's another maintainer was like
the revert looks good to me thanks these
things happen no big deal
it looks very simple it looks like
nothing at all but can you imagine a new
contributor coming to the repo seeing
this interaction and thinking wow if I
do something wrong people will not yell
at me I I will not like destroy GitHub
it's not gonna explode in my face people
are nice they can actually fix this
so it's really important to have that
kind of leadership that can show
vulnerability that can show that they
can make mistakes and it's fine we all
make mistakes
um just having the openness to listen uh
the transparency the courage to accept
change change is hard
um so it is nice that we have that kind
of support
it is a really good leadership knowing
when to explicitly give others the
chance to step up sometimes you want to
see other folks become maintainers you
know that you can solve the problem
faster
you know that you can solve this in like
15 minutes but what you can do is say
hey why don't you try it maybe you can
get this fixed and then you can
experiment how it is
um
it is nice also that we are trying to
plan for sustainability so the idea of
building leadership up in these projects
and fighting people who can actually
become maintainers become leaders over
time it's something that really concerns
all of us really because everyone's kind
of depending on these projects and we
should be worried about the Project's
sustainability we should be worried
about people not stepping up and
becoming maintainers
um finally I think also good leadership
is realizing not everyone is like you
people who will join these projects they
will be different and they will want
different things
not in the sense of technical decisions
or a road map or where the project is
going but maybe on their own attitude on
their own experience on their own
backgrounds and they will want to learn
how to deal with this inside the project
so it's been really great to collaborate
with these leaders so I just want to
give a shout out and thanks to everyone
so these people are listed on our grant
proposal so which is why they are on the
slide which doesn't mean that there's
not other people that we would like to
thank so there's Ralph gomers from numpy
and sci-fi Hana eisenmann and Tom Castle
who's sitting right there from
matplotlib Matt heberlin from sci-fi
yours London boss from pandas and all
the other community members Jeff is here
and a bunch of other people who are
collaborating and helping us do this
work and supporting us
finally I just want to leave you with so
what's next what do we want to do with
all of this uh so what we want to do is
kind of scale up and try to do this with
other communities as well like these
four projects are okay we can do that
but then what happens with everyone else
so we would really like to collaborate
and gather ideas from other communities
uh one case study is that for example a
lot of the things that this morning in
the fireside chat
um someone was asking or after that
someone was asking did you invent all
this is this something completely new of
course it isn't right we're all working
in open source we're getting ideas we're
recycling them we're reapplying from
other projects a bunch of the things
that we thought about
um and ended up realizing psychic learn
was already doing for example and we are
kind of cross-pollinating with other
projects other communities understanding
how they do things and so this is a way
to try and document what we figure out
this is is working for us maybe this is
something you can try maybe this is how
you can organize your meetings maybe
this is something that you should have
in your documentation all of that kind
of stuff so I invite you there's an open
repo you can go to github.com
contributor Experience slash handbook
this is very new still in the works but
you can open issues if there are
requests if there are ideas I would like
to see this content there or if you see
examples of projects doing the right
thing please let us know we would love
to hear especially from projects outside
the python ecosystem maybe we can learn
from rust from R from Julia from other
projects in other ecosystems
so finally I just want to make sure
um we understand that people are
different
it's wonderful to have Collective
knowledge but each person will have
their own solution to this problem right
so we want to figure out and meet people
where they are and meet projects where
they are so we want to make sure that we
understand their particularities that we
understand their history that we
understand how we can best support them
while still going towards a shared
understanding of improvement
and because I'm Brazilian I had to leave
you with some quote by Paulo Freddy
who's very
famous educator
thinker from Brazil who says some may
think that to a firm dialogue The
Encounter of people in the world in
order to transform the world is naively
and subjectively idealistic
there is nothing however more real or
concrete than people in the world and
with the world then humans with other
humans
I really do believe in the power of
community in the sense of people
connecting to other people doing things
together and building this connection
and I think this quote captures it well
that's all I had to say thank you
[Applause]
okay
there are questions I don't know do they
get microphones or I can repeat the
question
so well thank you very much for the
presentation
so coming back to what you were saying
about people are from being or design
during these open source projects it
might be the case that for someone doing
code they have a very clear intrinsic
motivation because they can learn from
the code itself but then if you ring
someone that can do marketing for
example they don't have like a marketing
lead to learn from right so it might be
more difficult to have that intrinsic
motivation so how do you think we can
solve this Gap or make open source
projects more attractive or people not
doing clothes
I think there's two things that we can
think there so the question is if people
are not working in code maybe they're
working in marketing how do they learn
inside an open source project if there's
no one else doing marketing there so
they don't have the chance to learn just
like other people will learn from coding
um experience so I think to there's two
things one is that I think it's a
challenge and some people like
challenges to join a project and kind of
do everything from scratch there's that
side and on the other side I think we if
we have more collaboration between
projects maybe this designer or this
marketing person doesn't have to be just
in one project maybe they can work
across the ecosystem maybe we'll have a
pool of people
working across the ecosystem I think
I think the battery is dead so I'm gonna
speak here
um so yeah maybe we can have a pool of
people who will split themselves in the
ecosystem and who can work together
towards that I think it makes a lot of
sense and I think it's something that we
should think about
hi Melissa thanks for the inspirational
talk a good way to end the pi data day
today
um can you go back to that last slide
where somebody messed up
foreign
now you know that's really a good
example of of promoting what I would
call
the umbrella of psychological safety
where people do feel comfortable about
making mistakes without being
reprimanded omit feel stupid but how do
you how pervasive is this
in the open source Community now I'm not
going to any names because I've been a
contributor for a longest time there are
some very snarky people who look at the
review and say some very nasty things to
you
and how do we actually change that
culture and I don't know how isolated
this particular case is but kudos to
this particular person who say Hey you
know I do that all the time so don't
worry about it but what do you think the
problem is is it the cultural thing you
always said is it just because the fact
that the open source Community is based
on the premise of meritocracy and if
you're going to be contributing the code
you better be on the top of your cream
I think you've already answered the
question partially but I think there's
also a component of
um hey this is not nice let's do
something different do you mind if next
time I respond to this person instead of
you maybe another maintainer will step
in and say hey this is not how we talk
to people here I think this active
intervention and active intention of how
you talk to people how you communicate
and how you can do that is one good way
to do that I also think that we have
unfortunately a lot of burned out
maintainers and some of the snarkiness
and some of that curtiness when they
talk to people online comes from being
burned out and so I think improving
sustainability and bringing more people
to be maintainers and sharing the load
is also a good way to try and not make
people feel like they have to respond
and then in that moment you know they
will say something not so nice because
they are oppressed for time because
because they have too much to do I do
think that happens for the extreme cases
I think we have codes of conduct
unfortunately that's how it goes so um
I don't know I think this is a long I
think this like it's not going to be
tomorrow it's not going to be next year
two years of Grant is not going to solve
every problem we're in it for the long
run I think
uh three of the projects using slacks
and when you prepare I'm curious is that
just sort of the way they were when you
came in is there like any I any thought
about consolidating to some sort of
unified thing
so you know how people like to each one
have their own like wow I want to use
zulip but I want to use slack but I want
to use this chord but I want to use a
mailing list and so we had a vote and
people voted on slack so that's more or
less how it happened
um I I don't think there's a perfect
tool I think like this is satisfactory
it's maybe not perfect but it's what we
can do now uh in the future if we feel
like we want to change we'll do that so
we had a like slack change their terms
of service
um we briefly thought about changing to
another platform and then they were like
no but open source projects that's fine
maybe we can work with it so it really
not that much thought into it it's
whatever we can do now
so
but yeah it was mostly a vote
hi Melissa thank you for for all your
work what you do I we already seen
amazing results after all this effort
that has been put but I was wondering if
like in this year and year and so like
how we learn of things that we should
not be doing and if so are we
documenting them somewhere
I think we have
um I think we are documenting them
internally but I think there's also a
responsibility to the people that we're
working with we don't want to expose
people and we don't want to you know
shame people that's not what this work
is about
um so I feel like there's we'll still
need to work on that and how to document
and properly report on that I don't
think there's been any like anything
major but in the in the sense that the
work that we're doing but I think
um maybe a few of the things that I can
personally say from my own work I feel
like I need to do more structured
understanding of what people expect when
they are onboarded uh having like we
learn from the Sprints for example in
the in the beginning we had Sprints more
like people come and they take like good
first issues and they start working they
look at the documentation and they start
working over time we understood that it
was much easier if we had this document
prepared beforehand with like here's
where you go to learn how to build
things here's where you go to learn how
to write your commit message so we had
like very structured uh instructions for
people to work on the Sprint so there
are a few things that we are still
adjusting
um so yeah I think this is uh we want to
do this like document the all of what's
going right and what's going wrong but
it's just like we need to be you know
Mindful and respectful of that
hey um quick question Melissa um I've
noticed that a lot of the statistics you
pulled that you presented earlier were
from the Linux open source Foundation I
was wondering if there's any plans to
run um surveys within the python
communities themselves
um to like better track the associations
of data over time and maybe see the
differences in the communities
um so I think it would be really nice if
some company would pay for a survey in
the Scientific Python ecosystem
um but yeah I mean basically we did uh
volunteer organized survey for numpy a
couple years ago we did another one
recently so that's as far as we went
with that it would be great but I don't
know that it's since cope for us just
because there's a lot to do basically
but yeah I think that's a great idea I
think we should have more of like
interviews qualitative data you know
understanding what people want from
contributions to open source I would
love to see something like that
great awesome thank you so much Melissa
[Applause]